[موسيقى]
كل عام وانتم بخير اهلا بكم في هذا الحصاد
الخاص على مدى ساعتين نودع فيها سويا عمل
مضى بكل ما فيه بافراحه واحزانه واحداثه
الجسم فيه فتحنا نوافذ على الامل والفرح
وفيه جابها العالم الخوف والحرب والجوع
خلال ساعه الماضيه داخل العالم تباعا الى
العام الجديد وكل الشعب يحمل امنياته هذه
اللقطات 30 من تايم سكوير في نيويورك في
الولايات المتحده والتي تستعد لاستقبال
العام الجديد بعد عده ساعات
وبعد اقل من ساعه سنكون سويا من الدوحه
على موعد مع بوابه العام الجديد وفي شرق
الكره الارضيه مدن العالمي تباعا صفحه
2022 واستقبلت العالم الجديد بالاحتفالات
والامال العريقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في حصاد العام الليله سنقف معكم خلال ساعه
الاولى على احداث المفصليه عاشها العالم
اوكرانيا الحرب التي فازت الجميع واعاده
رياح الحرب البارده وحديثا عن ارهاصات حرب
عالميه كيف غيرت هذه الحرب الخارطه الجيو
السياسيه للعالم وكيف اعادت رسم المشهد في
سوق الطاقه وهل بات العالم في مامن من
الجوع في عام 2022 لم يكن الاقتصاد في
افضل احواله فيه خيم شبح التضخم على كثير
من الدول فما الذي نستعد لمواجهته في
الايام المقبله دول عربيه عده كانت وما
زالت على موعد مع استحقاقات السياسيه مهمه
تونس السودان لبنان العراق العراق وليبيا
نتوقفوا عند مسار الاستقرار السياسي في
العالم العربي منذ بدايه العام 2002 وحتى
يومنا هذا شهيدنا تغيرات المناخيه طرحت
كثيرا من الاسئله عما ينبغي فعلها حر
وجفاف وعواصف ثلجيه وفيضانات سنتذكرها
سويا
وطبعا مونديال قطر 2022 كاس العالم الذي
شهد مفارقات كثيره ومفاجاه اكثر نسخه
عربيه استثنائيه جمعت الصعوبه وحطمت
الارقام وفيها ظفره الارجنتين ومعها
ليونيل ميسي بالكاس بلقطتين لن ينساها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اشعار تعبت شعب نهار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يمكن الخوله
سياسيه على خريطه التوازنات الدوليه
وتبيعات مباشره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن الكويت الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت وينضم الينا من جنيف الدكتور حسني
عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
جنوب اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا وكل عام وانتم
بخير ابدا بك دكتور خليل ما الذي حدث هل
ما حدث هو ان روسيا ببساطه ارادت ان تلتهم
اوكرانيا
المشهد اكثر تعقيدا
ولا كل عام وانت بخير استاذ عثمان وصفه
الجزيره وكل سنه الضيوف المشاهدين وربنا
يكون العام الجديد افضل مسابقه باذن الله
سؤال مهم جدا اعتقد بالسياق الاوروبي
والسياق الدولي كان يمهد لهذه المساله
كانت هناك مخاوف روسيه مشروعه لحد بعيد من
الاقتراب النيدو الى حدود روسيا وهذا
الامر بدا منذ عام 2004 ثم تكرر في 2008
مع محاولات النيترو للمدلات الدفاعيه على
الاقل باتجاه روسيا هذا ادى بشكل او باخر
الاستخدام هذا الموضوع باعتباره الذريه عن
قبل روسيا وبدات الحرب في 24 فبراير 220
وهذا يعتبر اهم حدثي ليس فقط في 2020 بل
ايضا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه بتتكلم
على 70 سنه على الاقل لم نشهد حرب اوروبيه
اوروبيه او حرب طويله المدى تكلم على 10
شهور ولسه قدامنا قد يكون 10 شهور اخرى او
حتى عام اخر او عام اخره في متعلق بقيه
الحرب
ادت الى ازمات كثيره جدا على مستوى الطاقه
على مستوى الغذاء على مستوى التهديد
باستخدام حرب باستخدام سلاح ناوي لاول مره
في التاريخ شاعريه على الاقل ما سمعتهادات
صريحه من قبل البوتين بهذا الامر اي ان
ليس فقط صراعا روسيا اوكرانيا ولا صراعا
روسيه الاوروبيه بل صراعا روسيا غربيه
يشمل ايضا امريكا في هذا الاطار وبالتالي
نحن اذا حدث عالم كبير جدا لا تدعيات تتظل
معنا على الاقل عقود قادمه على الاقل
وبالتالي نحن نشهد نهايه عام كان بيان
بهذه المساله ويتوقع استمر هذه المساله
وهذا الحرب وهذه الحرب في العام المقبل
بلا شك طيب ابقى معنا دكتور همم الساده
الافاضل جميعا طبعا حرب اوكرانيا هناك
تسال هل هي سبب ام نتيجه سؤال من يطرحه
كثيرون بشان تحولات السياسيه عالميه روسيا
والصين والقاره الاوروبيه الكتله الشرقيه
في القاره الاوروبيه كانت دائما محور
السجائر روسي غربي والحديث دوما عن
الضمانات لكن على عكس ماكنات على عكس ما
كانت تريده موسكوبات الوجود العسكري
للنيته اكثر زخم سياسه اعاده الانتشار
الامريكي تاثرت هذه النقطه فعلى وقع
ارتدادات الحرب تحركت الكثير من القطع
العسكريه والقوات الامريكيه من مكان الى
اخر والحديث ليس فقط عن اوروبا ولكن حتى
في المحيط الهادئ تمدد الناتو ولم يقتصر
تمدده على تعزيز الوجود العسكري بل راينا
تقدم السويد وفي لندن بطلب الانضمام الى
الحلف في اتساعا جديدا للجبهه المانيا
التي كانت بعيده عن مظاهر العسكر منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه دخلت النادي مجددا
وافتتحت الامر بميزانيه عسكريه بلغت 100
مليار يورو لتسريح جيشها
شرقا نسجت روسيا علاقات اكثر قربا مع
الصين وتم الاعلان عن شراك استراتيجيه
وسعي للتعاون في التغلب على الظروف الصعبه
لكلا البلدين هذا التشنج الدولي انعكس على
كثير من الاتفاقيات التي كانت تسعى لضمان
السلم عالميا فمثلا جمدت موسكو مفاوضات
الرقابه على الاسلحه النوويه وانسحبت من
محادثات ستارت النوويه الجديده مع واشنطن
كل ذلك حدث وكانت هناك تداعيات جيوس
سياسيه كبيره لهذا الحدث الجلل دكتور
شايجي برايك ما اهمها وهي كثيره ومتشابكه
كل عام وانتم بخير
افضل من العام الحالي ولكن
نودع هذا العام على راسات غير مسبقه يعني
الحدث المهم سيذكر في التاريخ ان عشيت 22
هي حرب اوكراني حرب روسيا التي حاولت ان
تغير جغرافيا اوروبا لاول مره منذ الحرب
العالميه همم الثانيه وكذلك منذ الحرب
البارده عندنا الان دوله عظمى كبيره نوويه
همم منبوذه محاصره حسابات بوتن الخاطئه
اكرده دائما انا لو لو همم روسيا دوله
ديمقراطيه لما كانت غزوه واحتلت
واصيبت الان بانكسات متتاليه وغيرت من
الجيوب واللاتيكيه العالم ليس فقط يعني
هذه الحرب ليست مقصوره كما يظن البعض على
اوروبا بل هي الهام كده اداه عميقه في شتى
دول العالم تؤثر على التسلح راينا دول
محايده طول عمرها منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه السويد لندن الان اصبحوا يعني قاب
قوسين اود ان يدخل الى الناتو ينهوا
الحياد الايجابي الذي اتبعوه راينا
اليابان المسالمه الان تريد ان تطور
صواريخ علامات ثلاثه الاف كيلومتر يمكن
مداها للرد على كوريا وكذلك لتنمر روسيا
راينا تحالف يتشكل بين الصين وروسيا همم
بوتين مازوم بوت يريد ان يفرض نفسه يعيد
العظمه الامبراطوريه الروسيه بكلفه كبيره
ولكن لم يحقق ايمن اهداف فلهذا السبب هناك
ارهاصات خطيره تهدد امن الطاقه تهدد ايضا
الامن الغذاء خاصه ان روسيا واوكرانيا هما
اهم دولتين في العالم في الحبوب وخاصه
معنا
للزمن القادم او للعام القادم لانه لا
يمكن لاي طرف ان ان يهزم الطرف الاخر
تحولت الى الحرب
مهم مهم جدا وسنتحدث عن العام المقبل في
الساعه الثانيه ولكن دكتور عبيد انا اسالك
اريد ان اسالك عن هذه النقطه التي اثارها
الدكتور شايجي موضوع المانيا واليابان
وهذه الدول التي ابتعدت عن التسلح بعد ما
حدث في الحرب العالميه هي الان تسعه لتسلح
وتعلن عن اسلحه متطوره وجديده ما خطوره
هذه النتيجه التي كانت نتيجه بطبيعه الحال
للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
يعني اهلا بكم كل عام وانتم بخير
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه استطاعت كل
الاعتراف
حصرها في منطقه معينه ولم تصل الى دول
اخرى صحيح ان الارتدادات وتداعيات اصبحت
عالميه ودوليه خطيره لكن في نفس الوقت
هناك حرص من قبل كل اعتراف عن طبقه الازمه
لازمه محصوره النقطه الثانيه قضيه شرط الى
اليابان وشرط الى المانيا وصلت الى
النتيجه بان نظامه اسمها بالنظام الامن
الجماعي والنظام السلم الجماعي سواء الذي
كانت ترعاها القطبيا الاحاديه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او النظام الجماعي بشكل
الدبلوماسيه المتعدده الاطراف قد فشلت في
الحفاظ على هذا السلم وهذا الامن الجماعي
وان اصل القوه الواحده لا يمكن ان
الولايات المتحده رغمتها تعثرت ولديها
العديد من المشاكل من اجل العلاقه الحشد
دعم دولي يعني بدون استثناء هناك دول
الغير في النهايه غير معنيه او تبدي بانها
تريد عدم حياز هذا عدم اليقين في هذا
النظام الجديد في رهسات نظام جديد هو قيد
الانشاء ادب دول مهمه همم اليابان وقع
المانيا ان تفكر في النهايه في في امنها
القومي
الطاقه ايضا طبعا كانت موضوع مهم جدا في
هذه الحرب بسوق الطاقه هو اهم متاثر
بمجريات الحرب والاكثر تاثيرا بالاستقرار
همم وتاثرا ايضا
في السوق العالم
وسلاسل توريد النفط والغاز وكل هذه الامور
الدول الاوروبيه التي كانت تعتمد على
روسيا بنسبه 40%
لتوفير اغازها وبعد الحرب شرعت سريعا
لتوفير مصادر بديله في السوق البديل كان
من موردين مثل النرويج والولايات المتحده
واذربيجان والجزائر وقطر روسيا بدورها
حولت منتوجها الى اسواق بديله كان للصين
النصيب الاكبر فيما يتعلق بالنفط شكل خطوه
وضع السقف لسعر برميل النفط الروسي من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا
منعطف اخر صعوبه هذا القرار على روسيا
تكمل في خساره جزء من السوق وتضرر سلاسل
توريدها حيث ان 90% من شحناتها تنقل عبر
شركات من مجموعه الدول السبعه وعليه كان
رد فعل موسكو بحظر توريد النفط الدولي
التي شاركت في القرار ما يعني حرمان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي من 45% والسوق الامريكي
من 10% من الواردات النفطيه
روسيا بدورها حولت الصادرات مجددا الى
الشرق وزادت التصدير بنحو الثلثين تجاه
الاسواق الاسيويه خصوصا الصين
والهند الدكتور عبيد نساء يعود اليك في
موضوع همم الطاقه هذا الى اين همم
يتجه وهل من منتصر فيه
الجانبين اشدان الحبل انجاز التعبئه
لا لا يوجد هناك منتصر قبل كل شيء يعني
حتى ان صار البيئه الذين كانوا يقولون
بانهم في النهايه سيريدون تحويل مصادر
الطاقه الى مصادر صديقه للبيئه الان هناك
مفاعل نوويه تم اصلا توقيفها منذ فتره
اعيده تشغيلها النقطه الثانيه اعتقد ان
الدول التي اشرت اليها مثلا مثلا الجزائر
وقطر والنرويج الغير ذلك وحتى الغاز الصقر
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اصبحت يعني
مصادر همم
اسهمواها مرتفعه جدا لكن القضيه انه صحيح
يعني ظهور اسواق جديده في نفس الوقت هناك
خوف كبير هذا الخوف هو ان الولايات
المتحده وبعض الدول الغربيه يمكن ان تلجا
الى قضيه وهو سلاح نووي في النهايه هي
قضيه تسعيره الاسعار ووضع احد ل- الاسعار
اذا استمرت هذه الازمه في السنه المقبله
اذا لم نجد تفاهمات فاعتقد ان اسعار
الطاقه من الصعب جدا
يتم تحديدها باعتبار ان هناك اسواق اخرى
في اسيا غير مهتمه بالشروط تريد ان تفرضها
بعض الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه النقطه الثالثه ام ازمه الطاقه
هي التي ستؤدي الى ازمه غذاء كبيره جدا في
العديد من الدول التي ليست لديها القدره
الشرائيه مثل الدول الاوروبيه ان تشتري
طاقه تشتري النفط وغاز باسعار تفوق جدا
ميزانيتها الداخليه الدكتور خليل العناني
هل ما تفعله روسيا يجعل الموقف همم
الاوروبي والغربي اكثر احراجا بمعنى انهم
لا يستطيعون ان ينفذ ما يريدونه لانهم همم
بحاجه الى هذا المصدر المهمه الطاقه
بلا شك بيتكلم عن دوله ااا من اهم الدول
العالم في انتاج النفط والغاز روسيا تعتبر
اكبر منتج النفط في العالم بعد امريكا
تصدر اكثر من وصفه تصدر ايضا جزء كبير من
الغاز وبالتالي هي تعتبر مصدر رئيسي
الطاقه والنفط في الغاز ايضا روسي تعتبر
يعني لاعب مهم جدا في مطلق عليه بوكلاس هي
منظمه التي انشاد قبل اعوام وتلعب دور مهم
جدا في تحديد اسعار النفط والعين قبل
حوالي شهر من الان عندما اتفق على خفض
انتاج النفط في اول نوفمبر بمعدل مليانه
برميل ايضا تعتبر انه اول رئيس للنفط
والغاز في في اوروبا والكاميرا صعب رغم
محاوله اعتماد اوروبا اعلى مصادر اخرى
مثلا قبل قليل سواء كان في النرويج او قطع
او جزائر من الصعب جدا على الاقل في
الماده القصير بتتكلم على البيع على الاقل
من استهلاك اوروبا خاصه المانيا على سبيل
المثال او فلان ده هو الاخرى من النفط
والغاز الروسي همم هناك محاولات من الدول
المستهلكه لانشاء ما يسمى بيه كارتيل
المستهلكين وادي يعني نوع من التطور المهم
جدا في سوق النفط العالميه يسعى عائله
حاولت موازات او موازنه همم كرت البتاع
اوبك اوبك بلس من اجل وضع سقف معادله
الاسعار لكن ايضا هناك امكانيه لان يرتد
الامر على الاوروبيين وراين قبل حوالي
اسابيع قليله جدا اضرابات كثيره جدا
اعتصامات احتياجات كثيره في اسعار
الكهرباء والنفط والغاز ايضا تضخم المجهود
الان في دول مثل بريطانيا 10% على الاقل
تضخم في امريكا السياحيه
مالك اقتصاديه واجتماعيه تدفع بهذا الامر
دكتور شاي جي ال ااه المنتج العربي
المستفيد ام غير مستفيد
يعني رب ضاره النافعه بالواقع انها حرب
اوكرانيا الحرب على اوكرانيا ادت الى
شيئين الشيء الاول ان دول الخليج التي تم
تخفيض اهميتها في الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
وشفنا الاستراتيجيه الامريكي الامن الوطني
الامريكي التي صدرت شهر اكتوبر الماضي
يعني لا يوجد في الكثير حول اهميه منطقه
الخليج العربي خاصه ان الامريكي اصبحت
الدوله الاولى المنتجه للنفط والانغال
ونتراج اعتمادها على النفط الخليجي
والاستداره نحو اسيا ومحاربه روسيا
ومواجهه الصين وروسيا ولكن الان تغيرت
تغير التوجه اكتسبت دول الخليج اهميه
كبيره شفنا تقاتل القاده الغربيين وخاصه
الالمان الى قطر والى السعوديه والى دول
الخليج من اجل يعني
فراغ
المقاطعه النفط والغاز الروسي او روسيا
تريد كما وقع امس ااه رئيس بوتن
تم تزويد الدول التي يعني وافقت على 60%
سقف برميل النفط لروسيا فهني في في مصلحه
لدول الخليج ان اعاده المركزيه والاهتمام
والنقطه الثانيه المهمه هي ان ما يجري
الان يؤكد ان هناك همم يعني فكره الاعتماد
على الطاقه المتجدده والفكره الاعتماد على
الطاقه الكهربائيه خاصه للسيارات ووقف
انتاج السيارات
كما كان متوقع في 20 همم
دكتور حاجه هناك ايضا موضوع القمح سله قمح
العالم وامه الغذائي لم يكنها في ماء من
خلال العام 2020 ججره الحرب فما عندي لاعب
الحرب في اوكرانيا في فبراير الماضي اغلقت
الموانئ وتوقفت حركته تصدير الحبوب من
اوكرانيا ودفع ذلك اسعار الغذاء
في العالم الى مستويات قياسيه فروسيا تعد
اكبر مصدر للقمح في العالم واوكرانيا خامس
اكبر مصدر حصه كبيره من السوق في شهر مارس
الماضي اي بعد بدء الحرب باسابيع حذرت
منظمه اليونيسيف من سقوط اليمن في ازمه
جوعا كارثيه
بعدها اتسع دائره التحذير وهذه المره من
الامم المتحده التي دعت لاتخاد الاجراءات
الانسانيه عاجله في 20 بؤره اثيوبيا وجنوب
السودان واليمن والصومال وافغانستان
وسيرلانكا ودول الغرب افريقيا الساحليه
واوكرانيا ولبنان في يوليو تنفذ العالم
السعداء بتوقيع روسيا واوكرانيا اتفاقيه
برعايه الامم المتحده وتركيا في اسطنبول
تتيح العوده الى تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
هدد الظروف الحرباء وعلق التنفيذه في
اواخر شهر همم قبل التوافق على اعاده
تفعيل اليه التصدير لكن بشكل عام لم ينتهي
الخوف من بقاء العالم على سفير الجوع بعد
تجربه مباشره شدت امنه الغذائي بشكل اسرع
مما كنا نتخيل
دكتور عبيدي مذهل يعني حجم التاثير لهذه
الحرب على العالم اذا ما ذكرنا ايضا موضوع
القمح وكل التفاصيل التي ذكرناها للتوك
هي قوه وخطوره الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
هي في تداعياتها الاقليميه والدوليه لم
تترك دوله ولم تترك اصلا نظام اقليمي الا
وقد تم سماء تدميره او تهميش يعني اصبح
هناك عدم اليقين عند همم الشك في قدره
النظام الاقليمي سواء كان بالنسبه للغذاء
سواء كان بالنسبه للدواء حتى بالنسبه
للنظام الامني ان يواجه هذه الازمه القضيه
الغذاء مطروحه خاصه في دول الجنوب كما
تعلم لانها القمح ماده مدعمه من قبل هذه
الدول المشكله ان الازمه الاقتصاديه التي
صاحبت الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ادت كذلك
الى ضعف الطاقه التدعيم هذا هذه السلعه ثم
ان هناك ندرت السلعه نتيجه الحرب والتكلفه
الكبيره
بهذه السلعه هذه الاسباب التي ادت في
النهايه ان القمح يمكن ان يكون فعلا مثل
همم يعني ازمه كبيره جدا الامم المتحده
دائما تقول بانها مستعده ان تلعب دور في
النهايه الوسيط لكن من الصعب جدا في
الظروف الحاليه النصر اللي انا اعتقد الى
همم لا تامين الغذاء لدول اصلا لا تستطيع
نقطه الثانيه يعني ما رايت همم بعض الدول
التي وصل فيها الحزب اليمين الى السلطه او
وصل الى البرلمان بدات قضيه الدعم الاساسي
يعني ان الدول الغربيه رغم ان لديها قدره
كبيره على الاستدانه وعلى كذلك ايجاد
برامج اقتصاديه تحفيزيه لكن وصلت في
النهايه الى محدوديه كبيره ضخم اموال من
اجل الدعم هذه المواد الاساسيه والا
زاويتنا الاخيره في ما يخص هذه الحرب اذا
هو عام صعب شهدت فيه اقتصادات الدول
الغنيه والناميه على حد سواء صعودا قياسيه
في مستويات التضخم صندوق النقد الدولي
اشار في تقرير الى معدلات التضخم العالمي
عام 22 هى ضعف معدلات همم لعام 2021 وكانت
بلدان منطقتنا من ضمن الاكثر تضررا كما
نشاهد في السودان ولبنان ومصر
وتبرز حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ماخلفته من
تداعياتك اهم اسباب مستويات التضخم
الحاليه من ازمه الطاقه والغذاء وانقطاع
سلاسل لتوريدهما وارتفاع كلفه استيرادهما
الدول المتقدمه مثل الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي ساعدت الى كبح جماح
التضخم باتخاد اجراءات ابرزها رفع سعر
الفائده ورغم تلك الاجراءات فان حاله
التضخم القطط بظلالها على الوضع السياسي
في دول بريطانيا التي شهدت تبديل رئيس
حكومه في غضون 50 يوما ثم اضراب واسع في
قطاعات عديده كما شهد الدول الاوروبيه
احتجاجات واسعه
وبات على الفرد في كثير من الدول مجابهته
مظاهر التضخم من ارتفاع تكلفه المعيشه من
سلع وخدمات اساسيه والغذاء والطاقه والنقل
يعني التضخم اثر على دول كثيره بما فيها
الدول المتقدمه
الدكتور عناني
وشاهدنا ما حدث في بريطانيا على سبيل
المثال وكان هناك ظهور لسمك
قبل يومين يقول ان الامر صعب وسوف نواجه
صعوبات
يعني منذ ثلاثه التعامل على الاقل اولا مع
كفيت نايتين واثره كبيره جدا الاغلاق شامل
وكامل في معظم دول العالم خاصه في دول
مثلا زي الصين نتيجه تعتبر لحد بعيد مصنع
العالم هذا ادى الى نوع من التابات
الاقتصادي نحن نستعد ايضا في العام الجديد
اي نوع من التباطؤ او ربما الركود
الاقتصادي في العالم كله جزء منه متعلق
بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا جزء منه
متعلق بالتضخم مرتفع جدا كما تفضلته عثمان
هناك ارتفاع للاسعار في بريطانيا 10% في
في معدل الغير مسلوق من ال 40 عام على
الاقل ارتفاع ايضا في الدول الاخرى مثلا
دول الجنوب دول الشمال هناك مشكله كبيره
جدا في هذه المساله هناك ايضا انت داعيات
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه كما قلنا ك- وحتى
سياسيه ايضا بنتكلم على اضرابات واحتجاجات
قبل حوالي اسبوع من الان اضرابات لعمال
السكه الحديد تدريبات العمال الطيران
ضربات الموظفين في المطارات خاصه في ظل
موسم الاعياد هناك مشاكل كثيره جدا هناك
صعود الامير مضطر في اوروبا جزء منه متعلق
به عدم تحمس للحرب روسيه على اوكرانيا
والمطالبه بي عدم وجود تكمل الدول
الاوروبيه في هذه الحرب فهناك دعايات
كبيره جدا اعتقد نحن ايذاء خريف في
اقتصادي قادم في العالم نشد فاروق خلال
شهور المقبله فريق اقتصادي ماذا عن العالم
العربي دكتور شايجي هل يمكن ان تكون هناك
كلفه سياسيه وباختصار من فضلك
الكل فارادي موجوده يعني نشوف ان هناك
ارتفاعات بجميع الاسعار خاصه الوقود تضخم
يضرب الجميع همم
يؤثر ذلك على الجانب السياسي اقصد في
العالم العربي وباختصار اذا سمحت
يعني في الجانب السياسي له تاثير بالتاكيد
ان المواطن يعني في الدول اللي فيها
ديمقراطيه وفي انتخابات حقيقيه طبعا سيؤثر
ولكن في الدول التي كما نعرفها يعني لن
يتغير الكثير الحزب الحاكم سيعود النظام
العسكري الذي هو يحكم سيبقى لهذا السبب
ولكن معاناه المواطن العادي هي التي ستكون
اكثر الى من واكثر ضرارا لان الدخل
المحدود والدولار يرتفع والعمله الوطنيه
تنهار ولهذا السبب يعني سيكون هناك المزيد
من الفقر المزيد من الجوع بالاضافه الى
الازمه همم الامن الغذائي اللي 800 مليون
ورده قبل ازمه همم روسي اوكرانيا كانوا
يعانون من الفقر وكذلك الجوع الان ستزداد
هذه والكل فستكون على المواطنين همم الذين
سيدفعون شكرا دكتور عبد الله الشاذلي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
الدكتور خليل العنان السيد العلم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه حدثنا من واشنطن ومن
جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ الدوليه في
جامعه جنيف
[موسيقى]
في العالم العربي كان عام غياب الاستقرار
السياسي عن عدد من الدول العربيه منها من
اجل انتخابات ومنها من لم يفعل
لتبحث شعوب هذه الدول عن بوادر الاستقرار
السياسي في العام الجديد في العراق شهد
العام واحداثا وتطورات سياسيه وميدانيه
انتهت بمواجهه المسلحه في الشوارع وساهمت
الازمه السياسيه في تاجيل تشكيل حكومه
جديده لاكثر من عام ثم توافق الفرقاء
السياسيون على حكومه برئاسه محمد شياح
السوداني مع انسحاب التيار الصدري من
العمليه السياسيه
السودان بدا العام باعلان رئيس مجلس
السياده حاله الطوارئ في البلاد واختتم
ذلك بالتوصل الى ما عرف بالاتفاق الايطالي
المكون العسكري بين المكون العسكري وقوه
السياسيه واثار الاتفاق تباين في ردود
الفعل بين مؤيد ومعارض لكن ذلك لم يمنع من
استمرار الاحتجاجات المطالبه باقامه حكم
مدني في البلاد
مر عام 2022 في لبنان على وقع ازمات
سياسيه واقتصاديه متواصله في حين فشل
البرلمان خلال 10 جلسات في انتخاب رئيس
جديد ما جاء على شعور الرئاسيه قائما
ويعول كثيرون على تسويه من شانها ان تمهد
الانتخاب الرئيس وتشكيل حكومه جديده وتضع
خطه للخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه
وفي تونس اجراءات متسارعه لتثبيت خريطه
الطريق التي اعلن عنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
تجسيدا لمشروعه السياسيه غير ان هذه
الاجراءات جوبهت برفض المعارضه التي
اعتبرتها احاديه وغير تشاوريه فضلا عن
كونها عمقه الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
في البلاد
ازمه سياسيه في ليبيا رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد طبيبه يعارض قرارات
مجلس النواب بتكليف وزير الداخليه فتح
الباشاغه برئاسه الحكومه وسط مطالبات
باجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
وما هي الاشهر قليله حتى اندلعت مواجهات
في العاصمه طرابلس ولا تزال الازمه طبعا
مستمر هناك ارحب بضيفيه هنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور صلاح الدين محمد الشؤون السودانيه
في قناه الجزيره والدكتور لقاء مكه الباحث
الاول في مركز الجزيره للدراسات اهلا
وسهلا بكم الدكتور طبعا ليس شؤون
السودانيه فقط ههه
ولكن دعنا نبدا من العراق
يعني
كانت هناك شفنا كلنا المظاهر داخل
البرلمان والاقت حمله صار ثم تراجع السيد
مقتدى الصدر عن ذلك
لماذا وصلت الامور الى هذه النقطه طبعا
البدايه 2022 كانت مع نتائج انتخابات جرت
في اكتوبر من العامه ال 21 وكان يفترض بدل
عام بانتخاب رئيس البرلمان حسب القواعد
وفاز الحلبسي كما نعرف ولكن كان يجب بعد
ذلك نجد الانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه المعتاد
فعلا جرى هذا يعني كان محاوله للانتخاب
لكن لم تعد الجلسات بسبب الفراغ او عدم
همم النصاب اللي حصل في المحكمه الاتحاديه
في فبراير
اصدرت قرار جعلت كره 600 ما يسمى بثلث
معطل يعني حصلت جلسه الانتخاب الرئيس
جمهوريه
بوجود بوجود نصاب الثلثين وهذا كان غير
موجود بالانتخابات الماضيه
طبعا هذا عطل امكانيه عقد الجلسه وهكذا
الامور حتى النهايه ضغوط حصلت على كل
القوى السياسيه اجبرت الجميع على ان ان
يتفق لا لا بالعكس الانشقاق بقى كان هناك
رغبه من القوى الشيعيه الاطار تحديدا ما
يسمى بيتار تنسيقي اللي هي كل قوه شيعيه
السياسيه باستثناء التيار الصدري انه يجب
ان تكون جزء من منظومه الحكم مع التيار
لكن هو رفض وبالتالي همم
بالنسبه للسودان
السودان الان يعيش العمر الرابع بعد في
خلال فتره انتقال منذ سقوط نظام
السابق خلال هذه الفتره يعني دخلت الطبقه
السياسيه
المدنيه والعسكريه سلسله ما يمكن ان
نسميها الاتفاقات المنقوصه والمنقوضه يعني
اتفاق الاول الذي نتج عنه
الاعلان الدستوري والشك بموجب الحكومه في
2019 اما نقدر لاحقا ثم جاء بعد ذلك اتفاق
حمدوق
والبرهان في نوفمبر من العام الماضي وايضا
فقط الان نحن باذاء الاتفاق الاطار ايضا
ناقص لانه هو اتفاق جزء ما بين المكون
العسكري وجزء من قوه الحريه والتغيير وهذا
الاتفاق ايضا يواجه مشكله في ان هنالك من
اقصى اليمين الى اقصى اليسار هنالك معارضه
شديده بالنسبه لهم العامل المشترك في كل
هذه ال- همم المسيره هو زياده في
ادخل من خارج البلاد هو كان مؤسسات
الاقليميه الدوليه مثل في الاتحاد
الافريقي وغيره او اطراف دوليه مثل
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات هذه عقدت
الوضع في ظل الانقسام الطبقه السياسيه
يعني هو يعني مش سهل ان احنا نتكلم في وقت
قصير ولكن عندما تحدثنا دكتور اللقاء عن
المشهد العربي في العمر
طبعا هناك خيبات في كل المرافق باستثناء
بعض النجاحات اللي يتحققت في الخليج
ال همم كاس العالم يعني طبعا هناك عمليه
تنميه تجري في الخليج بشكل عام وكاس
العالم كانت مثال حي على هذا البروج
والقدره على ان تجعل من سنه 22 سنه
فقط
رساله سياسيه مهمه
الدول العربيه همم مازومه اللي دخلت 22
بالازمه لم تنجح في الخروج من هذه الازمه
بالكرستها وزادت في التازيم وهذا حصل في
كل الدول العربيه حقيقه يعني العراق مثلا
شكل الحكومه
بال22 في اكتوبر كل رئيس الوزراء بده
يشتغل لكن انتهى العام
فقدان قيمه مهمه من الدينار العراقي
وخساره
هناك ازمه اقتصاديه لها هاي مشكله
ليبيا نفس الشيء ليبيا دخلت بعزمه عدم
وجود انتخابات وانتهت الان بحكمتين
وانقسام على المستوى السياسي لبنان الان
في حاله شبه انهيار اقتصادي وسياسي بدون
اي جمهوريه حكومه تصنيف اعمال الليره فقدت
حوالي اكثر من تقريبا 100% من قيمتها
سوريا نعرفها
والان في الافق الاتفاق ولكن اتفاق غير
مرضي عنده شعبيه المعارضه نعم كل القوه
الثوريه ولكن ليس هناك اراد الدوليه
للشعب السوري مثلا صلاح في نقاط مضيئه
خلينا نقول
الله النقاط التي اشار اليها الدكتور
لقاء اهم نقطه في حاله الانقسام الحاده
الموجوده في الطبقه السياسيه هي نقطه
سلبيه
وحاله الفصام ما بين الطبقه السياسيه
وعامه الشعب في كل دول المنطقه العربيه
التي تمر بحاله الانتقال هذه بالنسبه
لاعتقد انه النقطه المضيئه واللي ربما في
المستقبل انه حاله الحراك هذه والتدفق قد
ينتج حركه حركات سياسيه جديده تحمل افكار
واجدده تخاطب القضايا الوطنيه في كل واحده
لانه همم اذا اخذنا النماذج من تونس الى
ليبيا الى السودان الى لبنان الى العراق
همم تقريبا المشتركات واضحه الشعوب تعاني
ازمات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه خانقه الدوله
السلطات الرسميه شبه غائبه عن مخاطبه
قضايا الناس وحياتيه وهمم
الاقليمي والدولي
والحقيقه دكتور اللقاء فساد
مهول لا يصدق
اعتقد في العراق في هناك شخص يحاول يطلع
من الاثنين مليار دولار وحاول طلع هو نصف
مليار
ويعادل نص مليار دولار طبعا تقول الدوله
انها استرجع جزء بسيط ولكن طلع يعني
بالنهايه تمكن من سرقتها وعلى عينك يعني
هي بشوف اولا الفساد في العراق في
المنظومه السياسيه هو جزء حي من النظام
وليس من السيستم يعني وليس افراد ولذلك
شبكه وليست افراد يقومون بهذا النهب شبكه
ان سقطت يسقط النظام السياسي لذلك الامر
اكبر من رئيس الوزراء واكبر من اللجان
القضيه انا اعتقد شوف اذا تلاحظ بعد
الربيع العربي بدات هذا
الشد والتئذ القضيه ليست في الربيع العربي
وليست في الثوره ولكن في الصراع الذي نجم
عن اراده الحريه بمعنى انه نحن من همم
2010 الثوره التونسيه تونس النموذج الحالي
اللي تصوروا ايضا للنجاح الان في ازمه
ازمه خطيره نحنا ما تكلمنا عن تونس بدات
بازمه وانتهت بازمه نتكلم عن تونس دكتور
صلاح همم تونس همم المسار الذي اختططه
الرئيس همم قيس سعيد همم على الاقل من همم
تقريبا يوليو لعمل الماضي همم باجراءات
اللي اتخذها بحل البرلمان همم بحله كثير
من المؤسسات الدستوريه بما فيها الحكومه
وبدا بمسار جديد لتاسيس نظام سياسي جديد
ما ما هي النتيجه الاستشارات الالكترونيه
التي اجرها كانت المشاركه ضعيفه جدا
الاستفتاء على مشروع الدستور لم يجد قبوله
من الشعب واخر خطوه تمته هي اللي همم
الانتخابات التي جرت همم في الايام
الماضيه التي لم يشارك فيها اكثر من همم
يمكن نسبه 12%
ففي حاله توهان وحيره ذات الشارع التونسي
كانسا من اداء الاحزاب السياسيه للامانه
الاحزاب السياسيه سلم تكون همم اداب
المستوى الجيد ولكن جاء قيس سعيد همم على
راس موجه شعبويه واوصل البلاد الى هذه
الحاله في تقدير انهاء الذي يدور الان من
حراك داخل تونس قد يؤدي ايضا
لخصوصا لان التجربه التونسي ما تزال تحمل
بعض الاجابات على الاقل محافظه على طابعها
السلمي التدافع ماده في اطار السلمي ولم
يخرج همم شكرا دكتور صلاح الزين دكتور
لقاء مكه كل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]
من العاصفه يونس الى موجات الجفاف غير
المسبوقه في اوروبا ثم الصين والبرازيل
وصولا الى فيضانات باكستان هي كوارث غير
مسبوقه كذلك خلفت عشرات الالف من الضحايا
وخسائر بمئات المليارات من الدولارات كان
عاما حزينا على ملايين البشر وفي هذا
العرض نتعرف نتعرف على ابرز مظاهر التطرف
المناخي في 2022
[موسيقى]
ينظم
الدوليه
كذلك دكتور عصام حجي من ميونخ وهو عالم
الفضاء المعروف طبعا في وكاله ناسا
الامريكيه اهلا وسهلا بكما دكتور عصام
يتحدث عن موجات جفاف غير مسبوقه ثم عواطف
ثلجيه غير مسبوقه
ما الذي يحدث
ما ما يحدث هو التغير في زياده معدلات ما
يسمى بالاكستريم ايفنت هي هي الظواهر
الظواهر الحاده او المخاطر الطبيعيه
الحاده التي انهار زياده في عددها كنا
مثلا من ارى سقوط الجليد في المناطق
الصحراويه يحدث مره واحده مثلا في 200 عام
او في مئه عام
من اسبوع رايناه في دوله الكويت الشقيقه
وكان العام السابق في الجزائر
والعامله في السعوديه
فزياده وتيره همم ما يسمى بالاكثرين
ايفانس هي دليل همم محير وخطير على
التغيرات المناخي التي نمر بها والجفاف
والحرائق همم وتغير معدات همم سيلان سيلان
ااه كل هذه الدلائل تحذرنا من ذلك همم
كريم هل هذه الامور كلها كانت متوقعه ام
امم امفاجاتنا في هذه المنطقه وفي المناطق
الاخرى من العالم
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك ما تفضل دكتور عصام
حقيقه كل هذه التغيرات كل هذه الاحداث
المناخيه الاكثر تطرفا كلها تاتي موافقه
مع نماذج المحاكاه التي رايناها التي يتم
تطويرها لتصبح اكثر دقه واكثر همم فهمم
المنظومه المناخ المعقده التي نعيش فيها
ولكن لا توجد مفاجات بالعكس ما نرى دائما
هو ان همم ما نعيشه عاده يصبح همم واقعا
من ناحيه العلماء كل في كل تحديث همم
يحذروننا بشكل اشد ان التوقعات ربما ستكون
للاسوء كل سبعه اعوام يتم تحديث همم
التقييم همم التقييم العلماء المناخر
ان هم ثقتهم اشد ان التغيرات ربما تكونوا
اسوا علينا يعني همم
استخدم التعبير مؤشر خطير لماذا دكتور
عصام
المؤشر الخطير لزياده معدلات
هذه الكوارث الطبيعيه له اثار مهمه على
على التوازن البيئي والمناخي لكوكب الارض
فمثلا زياده العواصف في منطقه
الشرق المتوسط تؤدي الى زياده
تاكل السواحل مما يهدد
التاثير ارتفاع المحيطات في في في
المستقبل زياده فترات الجفاف تؤدي الى
توقف الوديان والانهار مما يؤدي همم في
حاله سقوط الامطار بعد هذا الجفاف لعدم
القدره على استيعاب هذه الامطار وتحولها
للسيول وليست كوسيله
ليه عمليه الري سيد همم اغلب الدول
العربيه هل كان هناك ما يمكن تفاديه بما
ان النماذج المحاكاه دقيقه كما قلت
الحقيقه ان ما يمكن تفادي هو يعني اخذ
نصائح العلماء او النصائح العلماء هيخفضه
الانبعاثات خفض الانبعاثات بالنسبه ل 43%
بنهايه هذا العقد هذا هو ما يعني نصحنا به
كثيره ومرارا وتكرارا ومع الاسف حتى الان
لا تزل الانبعاثات متزايده لازلنا في
المسار الخطا والدينا ربما عام او عامين
يمكننا بعدهم همم تغيير هذا النسق وربما
ربما تصبح فرصنا في همم تحول نحو بدلا من
زياده تصبح فرصتنا منعدمه فيعني لدينا
ربما حتى عام 2025 همم حتى نقوم بهذه
المهمه وهذا هو تحدي الحالي همم في
العوامل القليله القادمه شكرا جزيلا همم
لك كريم الجندي الخبير في شؤون البيئه
والمناخ همم والمناخ في المعهد الملكي
لشؤون الدوليه في لندن هاوس وشكرا من
ميونخ
الدكتور عصام حجي عالم الفضاء في وكاله
ناسا الامريكيه طبعا دكتور عصام ستكون
معنا في الساعه الثانيه
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول على صادق المحلل
والناقد الرياضي وهنا في الاستديو ماجد
الخليفي رئيس تحرير صحيفه استاد الدوحه
اهلا وسهلا احنا طبعا كاس العالم واحنا
نتابعكم ههه
حصول ميسي والارجنتين هذا كان ما يريده
الجميع واكيد الدوله المضيفه يعني سبحان
الله تحقق افضل ما كان يمكن ان يكون مع
البشت ايضا
طبعا قيمه ميسي الفنيه هي ضغط على البطوله
ميسي افضل لاعب على العالم لاعب افضل لاعب
في الكون اذا جهاز التعبير اخر عمره يحتاج
الى تتويج كبير كان ينقصه وهو كاس العالم
واستحق في النهايه مع فريق الارجنتيني
اللي كان ايضا فريق قوي ومتمرس عندهم افضل
حارس عندهم افضل لاعب فرنانديز
سبحان الله
الارجنتين الارجنتين قالوا يستحق هذا
قالوا استاذ دكتور علاء وطبعا يعني لا
يمكن ان نتحدث عن العام الماضي وكاس
العالم دون الحديث عن الحمل الغريبه اللي
صارت همم على قطر وكانت مفاجاه وكانها
منسقه واا مبالغ فيها وصادمه للكثيرين في
حقيقه الامر
الحقيقه ان تلك الحمله بدات من نظره
استعلاء من جهه ونظره حقد وحسد من جهه
اخرى
غربيون يرون اننا تابعون ويجب ان نظل
تابعين وليس لنا الحق في تنظيم بطوله بهذا
الحجم نحن اقل من هذا ولذلك كان الدهشتهم
كبيره
وصدمتهم اعظم عندما شاهدوا افضل مونديال
في تاريخ كره القدم ينظم على ارض قطر اما
بقيه انواع الحقد والحسد فقد تمثلت في
رغبه عليمه في اقصاء البطوله عن قطر باي
طريقه دون ان يكون لهؤلاء الحاسدين اي
مصلحه في هذا الاقصاء طيب هو في همم لقطه
البشت يعني شفت انت جاري
واخرين انتقدوا في موضوع الغريب انه حقيقه
انا لم ارجنتيني واحد همم يعني كان عنده
مشكله مع موضوع بالعكس يعني يسمح هناك في
بونس ايرس همم جداريه كبيره جدا صوره ميسي
وهو يرتدي البشت فيعني طبعا
لنكرز زملائه والاعلام الغربي والتحديد
الانجليزي هو من من الحمل المنهج اللي قبل
قبل كاس العالم فهم ما طبعا همم يعني
جاءتهم ضربه القاضيه بالفكره العبقريه
اللي يعتبرها انا من قبل سمو الامير تلبيس
همم ميسي بشت والبش يعني هو للكرامه
لمناسبات الكبرى همم هم الطلب الجامعيين
عندهم لابسينهم غذاء اسود صحيح فهو يعني
يعتبر فخر اكيد الارجنتين وافتخر وشفنا
التهافت على على قيمه البشته الان في
الاسواق القطريه فالبست بالعكس يرمز الى
الكرامه والفخر والزينه للرجل واحنا
بالعكس زينا يعني ميسي هو ميسي يرفع الكاس
الان صحيح
وهو يرتدي العجال دكتور علاء لماذا نسخه
قطر كانت النسخه الافضل عبر التاريخ كما
وصفها كثير من النقاد والرياضيين
وطبعا اشير ليس فقط كان في استفتاء للبي
بي سي واا فازت هذه النسخه من البطوله
باكثر من 70% بانها كانت الافضل في هذا
القرن ايضا
الحقيقه ان كاس العالم 2022 في قطر هو
الحدث الاهم عالميا في 2022 على حساب
الاحداث السياسيه حتى على حساب الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه على حساب محاكمه ترامب
على حساب ثلاث وزراء همم رؤساء وزراء في
بريطانيا الحقيقه لكن لماذا هي الحدث
الاكبر في تاريخ كره القدم على صعيد كاس
العالم اولا لانها البطوله الوحيده التي
اقيمت في مدينه واحده وكان يمكن لاي شخص
ان يشاهد 64 مباراه وهو ما فعله انفنتيله
شخصيا فاصبح تاريخا يسجل ولن يتكرر في
المستقبل ثانيا تلك اول بطوله في التاريخ
تمر بلا ازمه واحده بلا اي مشكله غير
طبيعي غير طبيعي في تاريخ كاس عالم ان تمر
بطوله بدون ازمه واحده بدون اي مشكله كل
الجماهير البريطانيه التي جاءت الى قطر
عدد الى بلادها دون معتقل واحد في حدث لم
يحدث في تاريخ صحيح صحيح مع اي نشاط رياضي
هذه البطوله شهدت اجمل نهائي لكاس عالم
اجمل مباراه نهائيه في تاريخ كاس العالم
من 30 ل 2022 الارجنتين وفرنسا مباراه
انقلابيه نتيجه تذهب هنا وهناك يعني هناك
كثير
الذي يمكن ان يقال فقط اريد ان اشير ايضا
الى الاداء العربي لانه هذا كان مونديال
العرب حسب وصف امير قطر الشيخ تميم والعرب
تركه بصمتهم بدايه من فوز السعوديه على
الارجنتين اللي كانت الفريق الوحيد اللي
فاز على بطل العالم وفوز ايضا تونس على
فرنسا والاداء المذهل الاسود الاطلس الذين
وصلوا الناس
جيده في كاس العالم هذا الخبر المفرح
واللي زاد كاس العالم يعني جمال السعوديه
تفوز على على بطل كاس العالم هو الارجنتين
وتونس على فرنسا وتقدم اداء جيد المغرب
وصوله لاربعه وكانوا غريبين من الوصول
للنهائي فريق كان ممتع تصدر تصدر مجموعه
اللي في بلجيكا وكرواتيا وكندا يعني العرب
قدموا انفسهم بقوه نعتقد ايضا لان لان
البطوله في دوله عربيه جماهير عربيه
اشعروا ايضا في وطنهم ولذلك كما يتعلم من
ذا تلعب في الهوم وغيره تلعب بئويه فهم
العوفي في بلدهم جماهير معاهم الجماهير
العربيه كلش صرفت مع الفريق العربي
كل نسخ كاس العالم هي الاجمل التوقيت
الجميل في الشتاء همم الملاعب الفريده من
ناحيه ثمان ملاعب تتحرك قبل الجماهير
والمتابعين والمحليين الفضائيه من ملعب
الى اخر سهل التناقل سهل البلد امينه
وامان ال 64 مباراه لم نشاهد فيها اي
مشكله جماهيريه او او فوضى كلها ناجحه
شفنا افضل نهايه على مر التاريخ في كاس
العالم
يعني فرضنا هويتنا العربيه والاسلاميه على
على الجميع ولكل احترامها بعد الاعلام
اللي ما احترامه في الاثناء دكتور علاء
طبعا همم كان هناك بعد كاس العالم رحيل
همم بلاي عن عالمنا هذا ويستمر النقاش حول
اا حول من هو الافضل في التاريخ ليونيل
ميسي دييغو مارادونا ام االي وطبعا هناك
من يضع اسماء اخرى ولكن معلش اسمح لي انا
ساكتفي بهذه الاسماء
الحقيقه ان من شاهدني ليه من امثالي الذين
شاهدوا كره القدم منذ مطلع الستينيات
يجدون صعوبه بالغه في مقارنه بلاعب اخر
كره القدم قبل بيلي شيء وبعد بي شيء اخر
تماما
75% من المهارات التي يستمتع بها الملايين
ونفذها مارادونا وزيدان ورونالدو وميسي
كله ابتكرها بيني لم تكن موجوده قبل بيليه
عندما كان يلعب باليه كان وزن الكره اثقل
كان وزن الملابس اثقل كان وزن الحذاء اثقل
كانت العلف مسموح كانت تحكيم سيئا ومع ذلك
بلي صنع ما لم يصنعه احد الارقام تتحدث عن
به المهارات تتحدث عندما تتحدث مثلا عن
المراوغه اجمل مراوغه في التاريخ صنعها ضد
اوروجواي 1970 بليه الحقيقه هو نقطه التح
في تاريخ كره القدم على مر العصور ما في
شكوى طبعا يعني هذا الجيل الذي شهد ليونيل
ميسي سيختلف معك ولكني يعني كل واحد له
رايه شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتور دكتور على
صادق المحلل والناقد الرياضي من اسطنبول
وهنا في الاستديو استاذ المسجد الخليفي
رئيس تحرير صحيفه استاد الدوحه شكرا كل
عام وانت بخير طيب
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت الدوحه هندخل سويا
عاما جديده الان مفعما بامل متجدد رغم كل
شيء بتوقيت الدوحه طبعا ندخله هو يستاهل
العالم هذا العام باهازيج الفرح ومضات
التفاؤل خلال هذه الدقائق يدخل العالم
تباعا الى العام الجديد وكل شعب يحمل
اماله وامنيته هذه اللقطات للاحتفالات في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو كما نشاهد من ساحه
الكريم او الساحه الحمراء الثانيه عشر
تماما بتوقيت موسكو
[تصفيق]
اه تمام
الان
سوف نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره ايضا
للاجواء في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف في هذه
الاشياء التي تعرضت لقصف الروسي صباح
اليوم هذه الصور الان هذه الصور تاتينا من
كيف هذه هي الساحه الاستقلال في العاصمه
الاخرى
امر مختلف تماما طبعا مدينه تعيش
حرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يبدا العام الجديد بملفات عالقه في
الميادين وعلى طاولات المفاوضات في انتظار
ان تحسم بين الاطراف المتنازعه القضيه
الفلسطينيه في مقدمه هذه الازمات اذ قال
تقرير للامم المتحده ان العام الماضي كان
الاكثر دمويه في الضفه الغربيه منذ 2005
اذا استشهد هذا العام 224 فلسطينيه برصاص
الاحتلال في المسجد الاقصى المبارك توتر
بفعل استمرار اقتحامات المستوطنين وحرب
قصيره في قطاع غزه وبروز ظاهره عرين
الاسود في الضفه الغربيه كل ذلك مع صعود
احزاب اليمين المتطرف الى سده الحكم في
اسرائيل ويحصل الفلسطينيون ان تشتد
ممارسات الاحتلال والمستوطنين ضد احد
في سوريا تواصل قصف قوات النظام مواقع
المعارضه في الشمال السوري اطلقت تركيا
عمليه عسكريه وخطفت مواقع ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه سياسيا زار الاسد
الامارات واجر وزير الدفاع التركيه لقاءات
ان هي الاولى من نوعها مع نظيره السوري في
موسكو وتواصل تدهور الاوضاع الاقتصاديه مع
انعدام اي افاق لحسم عسكري او حل سياسي
في ايران محطات المتقلبه شهدها العام
الماضي لمسار الملف النووي ومساعي احيائه
انقضت الجولاته مفاوضات التي جرت على مدار
العام الذي سبقه وبينما لاحت في بعض
الفترات بوادر قرب تحقيق اتفاقا بين الغرب
وايران تبدد تلك الامان مع تشابك ملفات
الاقليميه ودوليه كحربي اوكرانيا
والاحتجاجات في ايران
فيما لا تزال المفاوضات سد النهضه
الثلاثيه متوقفه منذ ابريل عام 2021 في
يونيو عام 2022 تم تشكيل لجنه الاثيوبيه
سودانيه المشتركه لتفعيل التعاون وتجاوز
الخلافات بشان سد النهضه وفي اغسطس الماضي
اكتملت التعبئه الثالثه للسد عبر حجز 22
مليار متر مكعب
تنضم الينا في الاستوديو الدكتوره فاطمه
الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره
للدراسات والخبيره في الشان الايراني اهلا
بك دكتور همم ايران
والملف ااا النوويه هذا ما اريد ان اسالك
عنه ولكن نرحب قبل ذلك من اسطنبول باحث في
اشياء التركي والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور
سعيد الحاج اين وصلت الامور بالنسبه
هذا الملف وصل الى مرحله
صعبه ااه جميع الاطراف لا تستطيع ان تعلم
ان الاتفاق النووي
لكن في الوقت نفسه جميع الاطراف لديها
كثير من الاشكاليات
والنقاط التي تريد تحقيقها مما يمنع
الوصول الى همم اتفاق لذلك فالمساله الان
هي محاوله للحفاظ على ديمومه العمليه
التفاضيه بمعنى ان لا يعلن فشل العمليات
تفاضليه لكن لا يوجد اي طرف من الاطراف
يقول ان الاتفاق قريب
من محل تركيز بالنسبه لها او بمعنى اخر لم
يعد من اولوياتها ربما امام التحديات
الدوليه التي باتت بعد قضيه اوكرانيا
وايضا تصاعد
الحضور الصيني في اكثر من منطقه في العالم
فلذلك ربما يكون ذلك صحيح لكن ما زال
الموضوع الايراني ما زال موضوعا مهما
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وذلك
الارتباطه بالموضوع الاسرائيلي هو
الالتزام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المتطرفه بقياده المياه هو الان سيؤثر
بشكل اخر وهو الذي يقول عكس الولايات
المتحده ان هذا اهم اول يعني نعم بالتاكيد
همم نتنياهو لديه همم موقف متشدد تجاه
طريقه التعامل مع الملف النووي الايراني
هو يدعو الى انهاء النووي او البرنامج
النووي الايراني عن بكره ابيه بمعنى انه
ميال الى حل عسكري للموضوع النووي
الايراني لكن هو يحتاج الى دعم قوي ومباشر
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لماذا لا
نسال الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي عن ذلك وهو
ينضم الينا من رام الله الان امين عام
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه عام وانت
بخير همم يعني ما الذي يعني ما يقوله ما
يقوله نتنياهو وحلفاءه من ان الاولويه
الاولى بالنسبه لهم الان هو موضوع ايران
كل عام وانتم شعبنا الفلسطيني وكل شعوبنا
العربيه بخير ان شاء الله
ما يقصد نتنياهو ومحاوله التعميه والتغطيه
على موضوع فلسطين
هذا هو هدف المركزي من خلال الحديث عن
ايران وهذا هو هدف المركزي من حيث القول
بانه احد اسس برنامج سيارته هو التطبيع مع
المحيط العربي على حساب القدير الفلسطيني
طبعا وفي الموضوع الفلسطيني هو يريد ان
يفرض الضم والتهويد ولكن هناك سبب اخر
الهجوم على ايران اسرائيل لا تريد ان تكون
هناك اي قوه في المنطقه تنافسها تريد ان
تفرض هيمنتها المطلقه على
المحيط باسره لذلك عملت على تفتيت سوريا
عملت على ضرب العراق والان تستهدف ايران
مثل ما تستهدف مصر باشكال اخرى وتستهدف اي
قوه عربيه تظهر في المنطقه حتى موضوع قطر
واستضافتها للمونديال اثار غضبهم بشكل
شديد هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه تمثل اسوء
ما هو في الصهيونيه وهو الرغبه في الهيمنه
المطلقه على المحيط باسره وتكريس من دون
عنصريه اجراميه يعني يعني في رايك انت على
القضيه يعني نتنياهو ومن معه بن جبير
والاخرون سيتحدثون عن ايران ولكن ما
يفعلونه سوف يكون في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
تماما تماما الهدف المركزي هو ما يقوم به
بفلسطين وخططهم واضحه ولا يمكن التضليل
بشانها يتحدث عن ضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه
بكاملها يتحدث عن توسيع الاستيطان بصوره
غير مسبوقه ليس فقط في الضفه الغربيه بل
في ما تبقى في الجليل والمثلث والنقب
وايضا في الجولان المحتل ويتحدث عن ان ارض
فلسطين التي يسمونها ايرث اسرائيل هي فقط
لليهود وحكم لليهود وحق تقرير المصير
لليهود فقط
وينه فرد مزيد من القوانين التي تكرس نظام
والتمييز العنصري ضد كل من هو فلسطيني بمن
في ذلك من يعيش في اراده 48 او اللاجئين
المحرومين من حقهم في العوده الى ديارهم
طيب انت يعني دكتور ذكرت سوريا الدكتور
سعيد الحاج عن سوريا الامر يعني بالنسبه
للمتابعين اصبح معقدا لل
فهم المشهد بالنسبه لما يحدث في سوريا همم
في ظل العلاقات المعقده بين جميع همم
الاطراف الاقليميه همم ذات العلاقه بهذا
الامر
مساء الخير مساء النور
الحقيقه ان القضيه السوريه انتقالات خلال
سنوات الماضيه بالمرحله الى اخرى او واضح
ان الان على عتاب مرحله جديده هي جزء
الحقيقه من مسار معين في المنطقه يقلب
صفحه ثورات العربيه وما تلاها من همم كل
التطورات الحقيقه خلال العقد الماضيه واضح
ان هناك مسار من التهدئه والمصالحات وفتح
الابواب المغلقه التي استمرت لاكثر من 10
سنوات ربما حتى الان تركيا جزء منها هذا
المشهد والدول الاخرى الحقيقه جزء من هذا
المشهد بعض الدوافع هي متعلقه بطيها هذه
الصفحه كذلك بعضها متعلق ايضا
بالتوجهات الاداره الامريكيه الجديده
واولوياتها ورغبتها في اثاره نوع من
الهدوء ربما بين مختلف الاطراف فضلا بعض
الدوافع التي هي متعلقه ببعض الدول
الداخليه الاقتصاد الى ذلك من هذه الزاويه
ثم على هامش الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
والعلاقات المتميزه مؤخرا او الدور
المتميزه الذي لعبته تركيا في هذه الحرب
والاتفاقات والاختراقات التي تحقاتها
ازدياد اهميه دوريها بالنسبه لروسيا
تحديدا وتوثق العلاقات الروسيه التركيه
كلها دفعت الحقيقه بطريقه او باخرى الى
فتح صفحه جديده حتى على مستوى العلاقات
التركيه السوريه على اقصد هنا تركيا
والنظام السوري التي لم تكن ربما منتظره
خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه هنا طبعا
هذه فعلا ربما
اسالك عنه في حقيقه الامر ولكن الدكتور
ذكر اولويات الاداره الامريكيه وقلنا ان
الاداره الامريكيه قالت انه الملف النووي
ليس من اولوياتها وهذا ايضا يعني يبدو غير
مفهوم يعني هل معناها ان الامريكيين
يقولوا والله حصلت على القنبله نوويه ام
لا هذا لا يعنينا اعتقد المنطق يقول انه
يجب ان يكون
بالعكس يعني كنت في طهران من فتره قريبه
جدا
وسمعت من مسؤولين ايرانيين انه حتى الايام
الاخيره هناك رسائل سريه وصلتهم من
الولايات المتحده همم الامريكيه همم
الموضوع ان تصل الى التكنولوجيناويه
القادره على صناعه اسلحه نوويه همم هذه
المساله في غايه الاساسيه سواء بالنسبه
للاطراف الاوروبيه او بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التطوير منظومه
الصواريخ وان تكون هذه التقنيه النوويه
قادره ايضا على ان تدخل في مجال صناعه
الصواريخ مساله همم مهمه جدا ومساله حساسه
لذلك لا يمكن ان نقول انه اسقطت من ملف
الاولويات همم الامريكيه ربما تكون ايضا
نوع من الحرم النفسيه بمعنى الضغط على
الايرانيين همم اجبارهم على اتفاق بمعنى
عندما تقول لي لست من اولويات كيف يشكل
هذا ضغط النفسيه
الى همم على الصعيد الاقتصادي على الاقل
همم تحتاج الى اتفاق همم يصنع همم
اقتصاديه مع الازمه الاوكرانيات
مع روسيا خيارات ايران على الصعيد
الاقتصادي باتت محدوده في في اتجاه الصين
لذلك نعم ايران تحتاجه اتفاقا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تدرك ان ايران اقتصاديا
بحاجه الى حل حاله لذلك قد يكون هذا نوع
من القول انه اذا لم تقتنص الفرصه وتسارع
الى القبول بما هو مطروح على الطاوله مع
المده هذه الفرصه ستتلاشى طيب قبل ان اذهب
للدكتور مصطفى دكتور سعيد هذه النقطه التي
ذكرتها العلاقه بين تركيا الان ونظام بشار
همم الاسد كيف يمكن ان تصفها لنا وما الذي
تعنيه
للمعارضه السوريه
يعني اولا بطبيعه الحال اضافه للدواف التي
ذكرتها لمسار المصالحات في المنطقه هناك
دوافع متعلقه بالقضيه السوريه وتحديدا
اثنان منهما الاول متعلق بمكافحه المنظمات
الانفصاليه وهي يبدو مصلحه مشتركه بالنسبه
لانقره ابو دمشق والامر الثاني متعلق
بفكره عوده عوده طوعيه لمليون سوري مقيم
على الاراضي التركيه للشمال السوري وهذا
يتطلب من وجهه نظر التركيه مؤخرا يعني
تواصل مع النظام على الاقل تقدير ضمانات
روسيه او من النظام بعدم قصف الشمال
السوري وبالتالي تحويله فعلا الى منطقه
امنه بشكل عملي هذه الدوافع اضافه للمسار
الانتخابي الذي اصبح من خلاله اللاجئين
السوريين او المقيمون السوريون على
الاراضي التركيه جزءا من ملفات الحملات
الانتخابيه دفعات ربما الان الرئيس
اردوغان لتبني مسار تقارب مع النظام كان
البدء من خلال التواصلات فنيه تقنيه ثم
تواصل استخبارات مؤخرا وزيرات دفاع على
مستوى عسكري واعتقد ان الخطوه المقبله
الان ستكون بطبيعه الحال على المستوى
السياسي ربما مسؤولين في وزاره الخارجيه
ربما يت الامر لاحقا كما ذكر الرئيس
اردوغان للقاء بينه وبين خطوه اللحظه ان
الارضيه جاهزه لكن هناك جهود روسيه واضحه
الحقيقه لتسريع هذا المسار ويبدو ان تركيا
معنيه بتسريع هذا الامر قبل الانتخابات
بينما كان النظام السوري وماطل رغبه في
ربما في نتيجه مغير في الانتخابات المقبله
باختصار لو سمحت
بطبيعه الحال تغير موقف تركيا من النظام
والاعتراف شرعيه والتعامل معه والتعاون
وهو بطبيعه الحاسب يكون له انعكاسات
سياسيه وميدانيه بطريقه اخرى ان لم يكن
اليوم فعل المدى المتوسط والبعيد ربما
دكتور مصطفى وصول همم حكومه توصف بانها لا
اكثر همم تطرفا في التاريخ هل الداخل
الفلسطيني والمشهد السياسي الفلسطيني مهيا
ل همم لمواجهه
هذه الحكومه بتطرفها
اولا هاي مش بس الحكومه الاكثر تطرفا
وعنصريه في تاريخ المنطقه بل هي الحكومه
فاشيه بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه
وكما يعبر حتى بعض الاسرائيليين هذه
الحكومه فيها نازيين جدد
قمه الفاشيه التطرف العنصري قمه الاجرام
التهديد بتطهير عرقي الساحه الفلسطينيه
يجب ان تكون مهيئه ولكنها غير مهياه حتى
الان كما يجب
وستكون مهيئه بتوفر ثلاثه شروط اولا انهاء
كل الانقسامات الداخليه والتوحد في جبهه
وطنيه موحده ضد هذا الاحتلال وضد هذه
المنظومه العنصريه الفاشيه ثانيا يجب ان
يكون هناك توحد على برنامج وطني كفاحي
مقاومه
يجب التخلي عن كل الاوهام السابقه
بامكانيه التفاوض مع هؤلاء المجرمين وقد
اعلنوا بصريح العباره انهم غير معنيين على
الاطلاق لا بنفاوضات ولا بحدود وسط مع
الفلسطينيين
ثالثا لابد ان يقود النضال الوطني
الفلسطيني والمقاومه على الارض ان يقود
ايضا الساحه في اتجاه فرض العزله
والمقاطعه على الحكومه الاسرائيليه انا
متاكد انه لا الفاشيه الجديده ولا
العنصريه الصاعده ستستطيع ان تكسر اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني او ان تكسر مقاومته
بالعكس هي الان خلقت كل المبررات لكي تكون
هناك مقاومه اكبر ونضال اشد وتصميم اكبر
من الجانب الفلسطيني على نيل الحريه من
هذا النظام العنصري البريد ليس فقط انهاء
الاحتلال بل اسقاط كل نظام الابارتيد
العنصري في كل فلسطين التاريخيه وهذا ما
اعتقد انه سيكون عنوان المرحله القادمه
شكرا لكن الان القوه الفلسطينيه المطالبه
بان ترتقي الى مستوى الوحده التي يصنعها
المناضلون والمقاومون على الارض شكرا
جزيلا من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
امين عامل مبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
واشكر من اسطنبول الدكتور سعيد الحاج
التركي والع الدوليه وهنا في استوديو
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره
للدراسات سهرناك معنا معلش شكرا انت طيبه
[موسيقى]
تميز عام 2022 بتصاعد التوتر في منطقه
اقصى شرق اسيا وتحديدا في منطقه المحيط
الهادئه حيث تسارعت وتيره تسابق الصيني
الامريكيه على توسيع دائره النفوذ اما
يجعل منطقه مرشحه لتكون حاضره بقوه في
مسرحيه احداث العالميه خلال العام الجديد
منطقه المحيط الهادئ باتت مصر حتى تنفس
الفعلي بين القوه الكبرى في مقدمه الصين
والولايات المتحده اذ تسعى بيجين لتعزيز
نفوذها وتسابق واشنطن الزمن لكبح ذلك الى
جانب الصين تقف روسيا ومعهما كوريا
الشماليه في تحدي القوه الامريكيه بينما
حلفاء الولايات المتحده هم اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان وفي هذا السياق الامريكي
الذي كان سريعا ومفاجئا من افغانستان
فالبوسره الامريكيه اتجهت شرقا لتعزيز
العلاقات مع الحلفاء ومراقبه نشاط بيجين
عن كذب
بزياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
منذ ذلك الحين بدات الصين مناورات عسكريه
حول الجزيره وكثفت تحركاتها في المحيط
الهادئ وصولا الى ابحار حامله الطائرات
الصينيه اليونج باتجاه جزيره تيجوان اكبر
مركز للجيش الامريكي في المحيط
ذهبت الصين ابعد من ذلك بتنظيم مناورات
عسكريه مع روسيا حتى حلقت طائرتهما
الحربيه في اجواء بحر اليابان وبحر الصين
الشرقي تغذي هذه التحركات ومخاوف حلفاء
الولايات المتحده في المنطقه رغم انهم
ينخرطون ايضا في مناورات عسكريه مع القوات
الامريكيه
هذا العام ان اليابان اعلن تعقيده عسكريه
جديده لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه شملت رفع ميزانيه الدفاع الى
اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي
والسبب حسب طوكيو وهو تنامي تهديدات الصين
وروسيا الى جانب كل هذا تتسابق الولايات
المتحده والصين الى تعزيز تعاملهما مع
لجزر المحيط الهادئ وعقد اتفاقات امنيه
مشتركه معها بتقديم اغراءات اقتصاديه
للفوز بافضل يتم نفوذ
يوحي كل ذلك بان منطقه شرق اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ ستكون حاضره بقوه في المرحله
المقبله من خلال مساعي تشكيل نظام اقليمي
وعالمي جديد
[موسيقى]
المحاضر في مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط كما
ينضم الينا من روما جوليو بوليوزي الخبير
في الشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه
اكسفورد ابدا منك سيد جوليا الولايات
المتحده دائما ما يتحدث سياستها عن الصين
هل نحن يعني يجب ان نتوقع صداما مع الصين
في تايم وان امم ان هذا يعني
نقل اللعيب سياسيه لها اهداف معينه ولكن
لا تصل الى درجه الصدام
وياسين
هذا الصدى ما بين الولايات المتحده والصين
وعلى ضوي التغير الوضع الديناميكي في
المنطقه ولكن
هنالك
منحن تصاعديا من المواجهه والتصعيده بين
البلدين
علاوه
من قبل
مباشره من قبل الامم المتحده بان الوضع
الراهن يشهد ان يتغير نعم هنالك رسائل
ترسل من
كل منا واشنطن وطوكيو لتايواننا لتجنب
اعلانيها لاستقلالها ولكن نعم بالتاكيد
تايوان هي
ال- ال- الوكيل ربما هي همم مواجهه
بالوكاله ما بين واشنطن والصين ولكن لم
تبقى الى مواجهها وصداما حقيقيه اذا علينا
ان ننتظر ونرى تفكك هذا التوازن اذا ما
حدث تغيير على الوضع الراهن
مثلا ان يصل رئيس الجمهوريه او يسيطر
الجمهوريون على كل من مثل زي الشيوخ
والنواب والذين قد يسعون الى
[موسيقى]
تحقيق استقلال تايوان تايوان
اهو ربما الحكومه التايوانيه التي قد
يجنحونا فيها الى اتخاذ اجراءات ولكن هذا
غير واقع على المدى المنظور ولكن هذا واقع
وطبعا هذا التوتر قد لا يكون قد يكون له
تداعياته السلبيه على المدى المتوسط
والبعيد وانت تتابع عن كتب السياسه
الامريكيه ربما في الفتره الماضيه اكثر
كلمه يرددها السادسه الامريكيون
الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون قد تكون شاينا
تشاينا فماذا تريد امريكا من
امريكا لا تريد تحدي كبير
للمنظومه الامنيه الامريكيه في جنوب شرق
اسيا منذ حرب فيتنام كان هناك عقود من
السلام
الاميركي في هذه المنطقه ااه وكان هناك
وجود امريكي دائم عسكريا واقتصاديا
وسياسيا في هذه المنطقه الهامه للمصالح
الامريكيه الذي جده خلال السنوات الاخيره
هو الصعود الكبير وتنامي القوه الصينيه
سواء كان عسكريه او التكنولوجيا او
اقتصاديا وجاء الرئيس شيء قبل 10 سنوات
متعهدا بمواجهه ال- ال- النفوذ الغربي في
منطقه شرق اسيا وان تكون السياده للصين
وليس للولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
تكبر الصين بتحالفات مع كل جيرانها في
شمال كوريا الشماليه وفي شركها مع اليابان
في جنوبها مع استراليا وتايوان همم بلا شك
والهند ايضا وهمم الرئيس ايضا نجح في
تاسيس تجمعين خلال العام التجمع الرباعي
اكواد مع استراليا والهند واليابان
لمواجهه النفوذ الصيني والصعود الصيني
وتجمع واكس مع بريطانيا واستراليا بنفس
الغرض همم واشطن التفتت الى الصعود الصيني
الكبير والتهديد للمنظومه الامنيه في جنوب
شرق اسيا وتعهد الصين بضم تايوان عسكريا
اذا استدعت الضروره ان لم يكن سلميه همم
لتجمع واشتون بجمهورهيها وديموقراطيه على
مخاطر الصعود الصيني الذي لم يلتفت اليه
مبكرا ولتفت اليه مؤخرا لكن من حسن الحظ
ان همم كوفد ضربه كوفد ده همم ارجعت الصين
الى وراء عده سنوات في همم السباق همم ضد
الولايات المتحده كما يرى الخبراء هنا في
واشنط نعم ولكن هذا طبعا ما زال مستمر سيد
جوليو عندما نقول ان اليابان غيرت عقيدتها
العسكريه وبدات تعلن عن اسلحه متطوره في
سياق ما نتحدث عنهما اهميه ذلك وما الذي
من ان يعنيه في المستقبل المنظور
طبعا هذا يعني
هذا يعني ان منظومه الدفاع الصاروخي
البلسيه اليابانيه
ستمكنها من التعامل مع
كم والنوع
للقدرات الصاروخيه التي تملكها كل من
كوريا الشماليه والصين وعلينا ان نتذكر ان
بعضها يمكن ان يحمي الى رؤوس نوويه
وعلى هذا الاساس
فان اليابان تتصرف
اسلوب شوي
قدرتها الدفاعيه وهذا ما جعلها تغيره
عقيدتها العسكريه وتعزز قدراتها الهجوميه
وهذا يتضمن امتلاك اليابان القدره
لتطوير صواريخ ذاتيه الدفع
قصيره ومتوسطه المدى وتحصل على هذه
القدرات من قبل الولايات المتحده ما يعزز
قدراتها وذلك فيما يكون بما يمكنها من ضرب
مناصات اطلاق الصواريخ لدى الاعداء وكذلك
تعزيز قدراتها في مجال التحكم والسيطره
وضربوا مراكز تحكموا السيطره في مراكز في
مناطق العدو ايضا مره اخرى هذا يعني لكن
هذا يعني ان اليابان تلتزم
مبدا
ولكن ليس من خلال الان اول اعتراض بل ردع
من خلالها
اذا سمحت لي فيما تبقى من وقت قليلا نشرك
سيد همم المنشاوي الى اي مدى يخشى البيت
الابيض والادارات المتعاقبه من تشكيل نظام
عالمي همم جديد تلعب فيه الصين دورا
اساسيا مع حلفاء اخرين ابرزهم ربما يكون
روسيا
اه طبعا هذا يمثل تهديد كبير لصنع القرار
الامريكي وهناك اجماع بين الديمقراطين
والجمهوريين على مواجهه هذه الرغبه
الصينيه في تعديل النظام الدولي القائم
على نتائج انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
هو اليابان كما ذكر الضيف الماده التاسعه
في الدستورها تقول ان هناك همم نبذ دائم
للحروف في اليابان لكن راينا اليوم تغيير
في العقيده العسكريه همم اليابانيه تدعم
ذلك هو الشيطان واشنط تقوم بكل ما تملك
وكل ما تستطيع من اجل منع الصين من اعاده
تشكيل منظومه الامنيه في المنطقه وهي حتى
الان تمتلك كل الادوات والوسائل سواء من
همم تكبير الصين بتحلفات عسكريه ضدها في
همم في مجالها الجغرافي وفي همم اضعاف
روسيا الحليفه المنتظر في هذه الشراقه مع
الصين واعترض ان همم الروس وقعوا في الفخ
في اوكرانيا وليس هناك حسم واضح
همم اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه الى حد كبير
تايوان الى همم اعاده رفع الميزانيتهم
العسكريه الى نسب غير مسبقه وتسليح همم
باسلحه امريكيه متقدمه جدا وموافقه
امريكيه كبيره من كل الوان الطيف السياسي
على غير المعتاد في واشنطن على مواجهه
الصين ودعم كل حلفاء واشنطن في المنطقه سن
محمد المنشاوي والكاتب الصحفي والاستاد
المحاضر في مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط ومن
روما الجوليو بوليسي الخبير في الشونه
الاسيويه في جامعه اوكسفورد شكرا جزيلا
لكما اتمنى لكم عاما سعيدا
[موسيقى]
كان عمل مليئا بالحروب والكوارث هذا صحيح
لكنه كان حافلا كذلك بالانجازات
والاكتشافات العلميه لعل الابرازها الذكاء
الاصطناعي وليس اخرها الاندماج النووي
نتعرف على اهم هذه الاكتشافات في هذا
الحرب
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من ميونخ الدكتور عصام حجي
عالم الفضاء في وكاله ناسا الامريكيه ومن
هنوفر المؤرخ والفيلسوف الالماني ايميل
تورس اهلا وسهلا بكم دكتور عصام الى اين
وصلنا في موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
ما وصل اليه ابحاث هذا العام في الذكاء
الاصطناعي خصوصا في مجالات الدراسات علوم
المناخ وعلوم البيئه ومجالات اخرى يعني هي
ما اعتقد انه مهم هو الذكاء الصناعي في
مجال استكشاف الكواكب بشكل عام وعلوم
وعلوم وعلوم كوكب الارض وفهم التغيرات
المناخيه تساعدنا الذكاء الصناعي في دراسه
ظواهر صغيره تحدث في اماكن متفرقه من
الكوكب الذي نعيش فيه ومن خلال هذه
الدراسات المجمعه نستطيع ان نرى الصوره
الى ما يمكن ان يقول عليهم سوء المستقبل
الذي نعيش فيه في ظل الطائرات المناخيه في
خلال العقود المقبله نعم همم سيد همم
لعلك سمعت في الفتره الماضيه احدهم قال
انه هناك روبوت همم بدا وكان لديه مشاعر
بمعنى انه رد من تلقاء نفسه او شيء من هذا
طبيعي يبدو امرا عصيا على الفهم هل يمكن
ان تشرحه لنامه وما الذي يعني
نعم بالتاكيد من ناحيه اذا ما كان الحال
كذلك ان الالات باتمتلك القدره تاع القدره
على الشعور
والمشاعر فان ذلك من شانه ان يشكل ما
يسميه همم
الفلاسفه هو الصبر همم وهذا يعني القدره
على الادراك
والاحساس ومع مرور الوقت فان هذه الدائره
فيما يتعلق
المعضلات الاخلاقيه يمكن ان تتسع
منه
لتتجاوز الانسان والمخلقات الاخرى التي
تعيش على وجه الارض ولكن الان في هذه
اللحظات المثيره للاهتمام عندما نقوم
باختراع او
استحداث هذه الخوارزميه التي تمكين اذا
هذا يعني ان هذه الالات ستشاركون العيش
ويؤدي الى ذلك الى تعزيز ما يسمى بالهواجس
الاخلاقيه وهذا ما يستدعي عبارات جديده
دكتور عصام هذا الموضوع
الات لديها مشاعر في وقت طبعا يعني هناك
بشر فقط
الاحساس انجاز ان نقول ولكن طبعا اكيد انه
الروبوت ليس لديه الشعور
ما الذي يعنيه صار عنده مشاعر يعني
اولا عايزين نوضح في سوق فاهم للذكاء
الاصطناعي سببه سوء فهم سبب سوء فهم ما هو
واستخداماته فمثلا لا يعني ان الجهاز
الراديو في السياره يصدر اصوات موسيقيه ان
السياره تغني لاني ان هذه الموسيقى حزينه
ان السياره هي حزينه الذكاء الاصطناعي هو
تحليل قواعد بيانات كبرى
واستطاعه استخراج بيانات معينه من هذه
القواعد لكي تقرر الاجهزه في قرار معين
فيظهر ال- ال- القرار كانه مشاعر او عاطفه
فمثلا الروبوت الذي مثلا يبكي او يظهر
عليه المشاعر الحزن هو بينظر في الصور
الوجوه المحيطه به ويستطيع تحديد الرجوع
الحزينه فاذا انه اذا وجد مجموعه كبيره من
جوه الحزينه سيرسم على وجهه ملامح حزينه
هي متوسطه هذه الوجود وش في هذه الوجوه
فهذا ليس انه يشعر ولكنه يراقب بدقه
ويقرر بدون اخطاء وهذا هو الذكاء
الاصطناعي وطبعا يعني الدول وصلت فيه
لمراحل مراحل متقدمه جدا السيد ايميل
توريس ما رايك في ما قاله السياسي
الامريكي المعروف هنريكسنجر من ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سوف يكون جزءا من الصراع بين
الدول الكبرى هل هذا ما يحدث بالفعل والى
اي الى اين يمكن ان يذهب
اعتقد ان هذا ممكن تماما في الوقت الحالي
الذكاء الاصطناعي
هو همم
ومنتشره في كل مكان وهو بالتاكيد يؤثر على
تقنيات العسكريه التي يجري تطويرها من قبل
القوى العظمى
بالتاكيد هنالك اسلحه فتاكه للغايه يجري
تطويرها في الوقت الحالي لذلك هذه التقنيه
التي يمكن ان توفر قدراته وامكانات فتاكه
دون سيطره او تحكم من الانسان هي تتخذه
قراراتها في ما يتعلق
بحياه همم شخص ام لا من تلقائي نفسه
يتحدثون وبالتالي هذه
فوائد قلق نظريه ولكن هنا لكم
مؤسسات مثل همم
مؤسسه تديه التي اطلقت صافره الانذار
والتحذير بشان هذا التطوير المحتمل مثل
لمثل هذه التقنيات وهنالك مقطع فيديو
موجود على اليوتيوب
يتحدث عن
توضيحات ربما مقلقه ولكنها مفيده بشان
باسم اسلام اباوكس لذلك نعم هذا
موضوع جدي وجدي للغايه ويستدعي
اهتماما وتامل ان اخلاقيا بشانه طيب ليش
يعني مدى شرعيه ومشروعيه هذه التقنيات
واستخداماتها في المستقبل لذلك نحن مهتمون
به في هذا اللقاء دكتور عصام حجي هذه
الامور التي نسمعها هي مبشره
على جهاز الكمبيوتر انه يلغي التفكير
الانسان اذا كان الصناعي مهم في القدرات
التحليليه وليس قدرات ذهنيه لا يمتلكها
عقل الانسان بمعنى لا يستطيع عين الانسان
ان ان تراقب مليون شخص لكن تستطيع
الكاميرات في ذلك والتعرف على اذا كان احد
من نادي مليون شخص مصاب بمرض او يعاني من
شيء والوصول اليه وان كان المساهمه في
علاجه هذه التقنيات نحتاجها لان الحياه
على كوكب الذي يعيش فيه اصبحت اكثر تعقيدا
من مكان عدد سكان هدف كوكب مليون او اثنين
او 100 مليون زياده عدد السكان زياده
المخاطر زياده التغيرات المناخيه زياده
الاماكن الذي يريد ان يكتشفها الانسان
بفهم الكوكب الذي يعيش عليه كل ذلك يستدعي
استخدام هذه التقنيات فانا لا ارى انها
مدمرا الانسان لكن ارى ان سوء فهمها هو
مدمر الانسان همم سيد جايملتونس يعني
عندما وانت قلت ان هذا يطرح اسئله اخلاقيه
لماذا ان كان في الحقيقه في النهايه
الانسان هو صاحب القرار
الواقع حاليا ما يقلقنا في المستقبل اللي
هو امكانيه تطوير هذه التقنياته الذي همم
تعمل بعيدا عن سيطره وتحكم الانسان اذا ما
حدث ذلك
سنتحدث عن الجهه المسؤوله وبالتالي هذا
يتعلق بالمسؤوليه الاخلاقيه اذا ما اطلقت
هذه التقنيات في ساحات المعارك تتخذ
قراراتها بنفسه فيما يتعلق باستهداف هدف
او لا
لذلك اعتقد ان هذه الهواجس مرتبطه بمالات
الامور في المستقبل ولكن هنالك ولكن
مشروعه في وطبعا
طوال التاريخ واننا نخترع التقنيات
ونطلقها في العالم ثم لاحقا نبدا بها
الحديث والتامل والتدبر بشان
تداعياتها من الناحيه الاخلاقيه
لذلك اعتقد اننا نمر به اوقات
فريق خصوصا فيما يتعلق بان هذه التقنيه
التي تعمل من تلقائي ذاتها لم تتطور بشكل
كامل وهذا يستدعي منا ان نفكر بالتامل
والتدبر في شان المضيق قدما في تطويرها
هذه التقنيات امنه توقف همم
[موسيقى]
ترتبط بها
الفيلسوف الالماني ايميل
في وكاله ناسا الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
بدا العالم هذا العام يطوي صفحتك كرونه
عاده الحياه الى طبيعتها في معظم دول
العالم ورفعت كل الاجراءات الصحيه
الاحترازيه من دول الاشهر الاولى لهذا
العام بعد عامين صعبين صحيا
صحيا استوطن الفيروس واصبحت الاصابه به
طبيعيه والتعامل معها اقل تشددا وبعض
الدول تذهب الى اعاده تصنيف
19 الى مرض معدي من الفئه به ما يسمح
للسرطان
بتخفيف من اجراءات الترسب
لكن الامر بدا يثير القلق اذ يخشى العالم
من عوده شرسه عادت عده دول واتخذت قرارات
بتشديد الاجراءات الصحيه على القادمين من
الصين التي تكافح في مواجهه الفايروس
متطلباته الفحوصات الالزميه
كثيره وقد يتطور الامر الى حجر صحى يقول
البحر
لكن بيجين اعلنت عن تخفيف اجراءاتها مؤخرا
والغاء الحجر المنزلي لاول مره منذ ثلاثه
اعوام وسطهامات الغربيه للصين بعدم الوضوح
في بيانات المصابين ليكون العام الماضي
عاما عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها لكن الترقب
فرض نفسه في الاسابيع القليله البعضهم
طلال المناعه في جامعه
الدكتور اهلا وسهلا بك نسمع كثيرا عن ما
يحدث في الصين ولكن ما الذي يعنيه بمعنى
في فايروس متحور خطير من امر ليس كذلك نبد
ان تشرح لنا من فضلك
ايه اول شيء شكرا
جديده بنعرف نحن وقت ال ال الفارس بصير
يتكرر وبيصير يتغير مع التكرير بيصير في
اخطاء الجيم تبع الفارس وبيطلعوا همم
طفرات جديده وهذه الطفرات طلعت
وموجودين اللي بتفرجيكي هون هون عندنا
البي اكس
2 هي دول ما عنديش جابه مضبوط على اجسام
المضاده
اللقاح بطريقه
في 10 الاف
يعني مليون شخص يعني
ان نحسب بين اثنين مليار شخص غير لما يكون
هذا العدد موجود في بلد فيه مثلا همم
ثلاثه مليون بني ادم
صح ما هذه هذه مختاره جدا معي تبع معقول
هذه الامور تطلع على السفر والسفريات
بيطلع من الصين الفارس بيطلع من الصين مع
الناس المسافرين اللي رايحين على اوروبا
رايحين على الشرق الاوسط هنا امريكا
بيجيبوا هالمشاكل معهن بقى هذه مهمه جدا
للحكومه الامريكيه اخذت قرار انه اللي جاي
من الصين لازم نعمل بي سي ار تنكون اكيد
ما عنده ها الفارس هذا لانه في من الطفرات
تكون الطفرات جديده عم تطلع وهذه صارت
بتصير كارثه طويله عريضه بنرجع عن جديد من
بلش من صفر على الامور اللي صار معنا همم
تلقحت مره واثنين وثلاثه واربعه
هذا يحمي من المتحولات الجديده ولا لا
لكن سؤال كويس انا بدي اوضح اللقاحات
اللقاحات
بدافع عنها ما يفوت الواحد على المستشفى
ما يفوت على الاكسجين ما في وفيات ما في
التنفس الصناعي هذا مهم جدا
بس حتى لياخذ اللقاح بيقدر يلقط الكوففت
بصير معه الكوفتي معه حمى على اسبوعين هلا
الدراسه جديده طلعت همم
اللقاح اجدد واحد اللي طلع فعلا
بيعملوه بيشتغل كمان على الطفرات الجديده
من الصين علينا ليه لانه التكرر كبير اذا
عندك اثنين مليون شخص يا عم بيتكرر عنده
الفيروس
لا نعلم انه في في بروتيكشن في عندنا
بروتيكشن بس لحقتك ليه حتى لو عندنا يعني
حتى حمايه حتى لو البكتيم بيعطينا حمايه
ضد المرض القوي ضد نفوت على المستشفى
دراسه جديده طلعت من اسبوع ونصف بواشنطن
يونيفرستيتي فرجت انه اللي عم بصير عنده
مره ثانيه
كل ما يصير معك كل ما في خطر يصير مشاكل
في الكلاوي في القلب في اللي همم
وكمان ما انت اللي يصير مشاكل في الراس
بدنا نفهم انه هذا الفارس بيعطي جلطات
صغيره هذا الفيروس
القطع مره ثانيه طيب المره الثانيه هذا
الكري اللي كان عندك يا بيو على ارض
بينكسر مش كل مره مع مين دكتور دكتور
خاصه بالناس الذين ربما يسافرون همم كثيرا
وبالتالي هم عرضه لي الاختلاط بعدد كبير
من همم من الناس
ما في جاك هل لان صحيح بتعرف كيف كمان هلا
المغرب كمان منعت مين ما كان جاي من الصين
هلا طلعت جديده بعبدار المغرب منعت اي شخص
جاي من الصين ما بيقدر يفوت على على على
المغرب والصين نفسها هاقول لك الصين نفسها
منعت كمان احد يجيء على الصين من دومه
يعمل بي سي ار ويعمل ويعمل تست لانه في
ناس يقول لك انه لا ما مضبوط كيف انه مثلا
اوروبا خصوصا امريكا قالت انه احنا قبل
الاشخاص من الصين بدنا نعمل هذه مهمه اخر
شيء الكمامه مهمه جدا
بطريقه مضبوطه شكرا واذا الله راد 20 22
الامور تتحسن ان شاء الله نتمنى السلامه
للجميع وكل عام وانت بخير
لا يمكن المرور على ما مررنا به خلال
العام الماضي دون الوقوف على رحيل اسطوره
كره القدم البرازيلي في الليل محطات من
حياه النجم البرازيلي نتبعها معي
[موسيقى]
نهايه هذه التغطيه الخاصه لحصاد لعام 2022
استشراف العام الجديد كل عام وانتم بخير
ونترككم مع لقطات اخرى عشناها العمل
[موسيقى]